all of the spider-man films tend to
feature the same elements over and over
again well a lot of its worked well for
the character for about sixty years you
could go to the theater and play Spidey
bingo pretty easily here are things that
we see in every single spider-man movie
let's start with a gimme here if you
have a nephew or niece and you find out
they've been bitten by a radioactive
spider and developed fantastic abilities
like sticking to walls or super-strength
pack your bags and get out of town as
fast as you can otherwise you're headed
for disaster admittedly the death of his
uncle is the most important part of
spider-man's origin story but still
watching an old man get shot starts to
lose its impact when you've seen it over
and over which is especially problematic
in the Sam Raimi spider-man trilogy we
get Uncle Ben's murder happening in the
first film a flashback and tons of
references to it and spider-man 2 and a
completely different version of it that
involves the sad sack movie version of
The Sandman making up a huge chunk of
the plots of spider-man 3 remember Ben
Parker the old man is shot down in cold
blood it should probably be noted that
this particular brand of tragedy isn't
limited to Ben in spider-man into the
spider verse Miles Morales watches as
his own uncle is killed in front of him
as for the MCU those movies have managed
to avoid even a mention of the late Ben
Parker so far with only a couple of
oblique references to Peters defining
tragedy far from home however is going
to take place in the aftermath of Tony
Stark's death he's not Peters uncle by
relation but he's definitely served as a
father figure and if there was ever
someone in Peters life who fit the weird
uncle archetype it's that guy one of the
most interesting choices in spider-man's
design is that he's one of the few
American superheroes whose costume
leaves him completely covered from head
to toe his mask doesn't even have a
mouth just a pair of big opaque eyes
this works pretty well in comics but in
movies where actors use their faces to
you know act it presents a bit of a
problem that's probably why the
spider-man we see in the movie theater
seems like he'll do whatever he can to
get out of that mask regardless of how
it impacts his secret identity again the
Raimi trilogy is the biggest offender in
this regard
not only does Peter's mass gets shredded
by billions with a frequency that makes
you wonder
just how many spares he has laying
around he'll occasionally just whip the
whole thing off
sure it's a lot easier to tell a
character struggling when you can see
their face but eventually people are
going to wonder why that kid who's
always taking pictures of spider-man
never seems to catch him without his
mask on along the same lines Home Coming
features a recreation of the famous
comic book scene where Spidey fights his
way out from underneath tons of rubble
in the comic the mask stays on but on
the big screen Tom Holland Spidey takes
his mask off to get some fresh air and
keeps it off so that we can see
empowering through his super heroic feat
of strength Andrew Garfield's Peter
Parker shows off his face an amazing
spider-man to help calm down a boy who's
in danger it even extends the animated
acting in into the spider verse where
Spidey loses his mask just before he's
killed by the kingpin and Peter bee
spends most of the movie unmasked and in
sweatpants there are very few things
that superhero movies love as much as a
good old-fashioned dose of crucifixion
imagery you might recall the scene in
Man of Steel for instance where our
hero's ghostly space father tells the
son he sent to earth that he can save
everyone prompting Superman to stick his
arms out and start hovering in a pose
that's pretty familiar to anyone who's
ever been inside a church well that's
the least subtle example of this trope
spider-man's movies have even more of it
in action that's probably to be expected
in a story of great power and great
responsibility but once you start
noticing it you'll find it happens a lot
Spidey's stopping the train in
spider-man 2 is the most obvious
instance but when Peter tries to hold
the ferry together in homecoming we get
the same thing in a pretty similar shot
spider-man 3 even has an entire sequence
that takes place in a church finally
adding parasitic alien symbiotes the
classic biblical imagery into the spider
verse actually manages to parody the
movies crucifix ation twice in the first
two minutes including a shot showing a
Spidey bathed and rays of sunlight that
give him just a tiny bit of a halo one
of the most compelling parts of
spider-man's story is the impact that
his super heroic career has on his soap
opera of a love life it's the source of
endless drama and it usually gets pretty
complicated the same goes for the movies
every single spider-man film has a love
story right there at the core of its
plot with all the twists and turns
that you'd expect in the rainy films it
was Peters on-again off-again
relationship with Mary Jane Watson which
started out complicated and only gets
more tangled as the films continue
especially when Gwen Stacy shows up in
spider-man 3 an amazing spider-man Gwen
was free of a love triangle but that
relationship had no shortage of speed
bumps in the first film Gwen's dad
wanted to arrest spider-man for his
vigilante activity I think he stands for
what you stand for so protecting
innocent people from bad guys I stand
for law and order son that's what I
stand for okay I wear a badge
this guy wears a mask and in the second
a series of spats wound up leading to
Gwen's tragic death
homecoming through a different kind of
wrench into the gears with Peters crush
on classmate Liz not only did he have to
deal with constantly letting his friends
down due to his arachnid activities he
also had to contend with the reveal that
her dad was a supervillain who figured
out Peter was spider-man literally ten
minutes after meeting him good old
spider-man into the spider verse
complicates matters further thanks to
its dimension-hopping plots we've got a
Peter Parker who's dealing with a
divorce from Mary Jane with whom he's
clearly still in love and a different
Mary Jane who's dealing with the death
of her worlds Peter Parker and those are
just the minor characters the main
romantic tension in that movie is
between two people from different
realities that's a tough one there is
long-distance relationships and then
there's my girlfriend you don't know her
she lives on earth 65 spider-man's
roster of enemies is packed with
characters who are actually pretty
sympathetic unlike same murderous
clown's I'd only want to watch the world
burn super villains like the lizard and
the Sandman have motivations that we can
relate to and come with a heaping
helping of pathos that the movies are
more than willing to bring to the screen
the Green Goblin and spider-man is the
outlier here since it's pretty hard to
be sympathetic when your pumpkin bombing
an old lady's bedroom while she's saying
her bedtime prayers
that again even he has a scene where
Norman Osborn is being tormented by his
own alternate personality Doc Ock and
spider-man 2 is shown to be a pretty
decent guy before he's driven to
multi-armed criminal insanity and an
amazing spider-man Curt Connors the
lizard just wants to regrow his lost arm
the vulture in homecoming is maybe the
least sympathetic guy of the bunch not
kill you and everybody loved for all his
talk about sticking up for the little
guy Adrian Toomes drives a Jaguar and
owns a massive house in New York City
bought and paid for with the profits
from his high-tech arms-dealing business
but still his stated motivation of
wanting to take care of his family is
hard to argue with and if nothing else
he keeps Peters identity a secret rather
than seeking revenge into the spider
verse goes the furthest with this not
only do we see the Prowler as a regular
guy hanging out with his favorite nephew
but even the kingpin has a shred of
sympathy in there yes he kills
spider-man with his bare hands and had a
plan that might have destroyed all of
reality but it all comes from his desire
to see his wife and son again their
methods are bad but their desires are
very human and pretty far from world
domination in his first appearance
spider-man didn't start out with his
familiar spider suit instead his first
outing after getting his powers was in a
pretty terrible homemade ensemble and
that's an idea that the movies have kept
around there's always a bad costume
first in spider-man it was a recreation
of a scene from the original comic we
fought a pro wrestler while wearing a
sweat suit and ski mask tricked out with
a stenciled spider on the chest an
amazing spider-man it was a red mask
with dark wraparound shades the MCU
actually flipped the script a little by
starting Peter off at least as far as
the audience is concerned in a comics
accurate version of his famous red and
blue suit provided by Tony Stark it's
only at the end of homecoming that he
goes back to his homemade hoodie into
the spider verse however takes the cake
on this particular trope with bad
costumes all over the place not only
does Peter spend most of the movie
rocking sweatpants and mismatched shoes
but Miles Morales doesn't get his
costume until the very end before that
most of his spidery adventures take
place while he's
wearing a cheap spider-man Halloween
costume purchased of course from smiling
Stanley no refunds incidentally these
are all just bad costumes if you're
looking for the evil costumes well
that's a different guy oh good now
that's vital the heads off order
spider-man's life is pretty much defined
by tragedy it's the core of his
character the hard-luck hero aspect that
makes him so easy to relate to but if
the movies go back to that well all the
time it gets both boring and a little
too depressing as much as we like
watching him get knocked down it's
always better to see him get back up
again that's why the movies always show
us something to remind us that being
spider-man is actually kind of Awesome
and more than a little fun but after
everything I still love being spider-man
I mean who wouldn't be spider-verse
gives us all kinds of moments like this
from spider-man cutting an album of
Christmas carols to the extended comedy
of miles accidentally getting his hand
stuck to Gwen Stacy's hair
throw in some Karate Kid style
web-swinging lessons and it does a great
job of showing us that having
superpowers is actually pretty cool
the Raimi movies do it too leaning into
zany comedy with Peter zipping around
the city on his web lines to deliver
pizza he even looks like he's having fun
with that dance number even if no one
else is amazing spider-man 2 takes that
to the next level with Spidey getting to
his graduation through a series of wild
rides and slapstick crime-fighting high
jinks it's homecoming that does this
best though with the montage of Peters
after-school activities as the friendly
neighborhood superhero not only is he
excited to get out there and start doing
good he gets a churro from a nice lady
that he eats while hanging out on a fire
escape and even does a backflip when
he's asked to by members of a public
that's what sets spider-man apart from
the other superheroes he's the guy who
will stop and argue with you about who
makes the best sandwich sandwich in
Queens
sohave is pretty good too much bread I
like bread check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]